c'est la première fois cinq colonnes à
la une est venu s'inscrire sur la rampe
du journal lumineux de berlin test dans
cette zone dite encore zone soviétique
ce qui j'ai voulu savoir pourquoi est
synonyme de désert d'insolite de
solitude
par un hasard dialectique truffé de
miradors de no man's land de brouillard
et de policiers en éveil
[Applaudissements]
l'allemagne de l'est l'autre allemagne
c'est le bout du monde et pourtant
et
on
[Musique]
êtes vous surpris moi je n'ai pas été
surpris unis attendent
il ya tout autant de brouillard au petit
matin dans les rues vides de berlin
ouest
et puis les rues s'animent à berlin est
comme à berlin ouest et vous avez le
visage d'une ville de vitrines deux
allemagnes s'affrontent mais regardez
bien ces hommes et ces femmes que vous
côtoyez waza d'un trottoir ou d'une
vitrine
ils sont allemands avant et pendant la
guerre il était comme tous ceux de
l'autre allemagne citoyens du grand
reich d'adolphe hitler
aujourd'hui ils sont 18 millions de
citoyens de république démocratique
allemande
pourquoi et bien simplement parce qu à
yalta les vainqueurs 45 ans ont décidé
qu'un partage et l'allemagne pour la
surveiller auquel ne soit plus là
terriblement et l'allemagne de l'est se
souvient elle aussi dans sa chair d'un
passé dont elle ne peut plus rien
ignorer
buchenwald est aussi un souvenir mieux
qu'un souvenir
leur mort celui de la complaisance ou de
la différence à l'est comme à l'ouest
l'allemand ne doit pas oublier qu'il ne
doit pas oublier l'horreur des comme la
mort quand il vit dans le présent quand
il songe à l'avenir la référence c'est
le nazisme
[Musique]
je
mademoiselle quels souvenirs avez-vous
du nazisme
personnellement je n'ai pas de souvenir
parce que j'étais trop jeune à la fin de
la guerre dans notre campagne
c'était aussi bien tranquille
je n'ai pas entendu de trop de morts
dans ma famille mais en discutant avec
mes parents qui étaient na vi et qui
n'ont pas changé d'opinion qui n'ont
presque pas changé d'opinion
je vois que le nazisme était vraiment
inhumain est terrible c'est douloureux
douloureux de discuter avec mes parents
2 par exemple des juifs je suis élevé
dans l'antisémitisme et je ne peux pas
persuadé mes parents qui n'ont pas
raison et qu'ils n'avaient pas raison
mais c'est vrai cette responsabilité
peso allemands de l'est mais
actuellement il faut repartir tout seul
quand ce petit propriétaire de saxe ou
alors en collectivité
la collectivité agricole c'est le secret
du redressement intérieure de
l'allemagne de l'est
il fallait vivre et faire vivre dans un
pays isolé ruiné par la guerre il y
avait-il d'autres solutions que de faire
bourse commune
c'est devenu raison d'état la politique
ap le reste est dans sa campagne de saxe
comme dans le chantier naval de rostock
l'allemand pense désormais selon les
canons d'une politique dont il apprend
les termes
regardez dietrick locle à 28 ans il est
contremaître à rostock il parle au nom
du socialisme comme d'autres parlait au
nom de mais c'était hier je les ai
retrouvés chez lui
le support qu'est ce que le capitalisme
gravette à lesbos tu as ce sont des gens
qui aspirent à des profits en exploitant
plus ou moins les majorités car on en
profite thor manigat au stade marcel
chaque son est ce que vous considérez
que le capitalisme est un ennemi de
l'allemagne démocratique
les ennemis du socialisme sont les
militaristes et les revend schiste et
qui veulent ravoir
il n'aura partie intrus dans les
merveilleux
il y une armée nationale populaire
d'après vous est ce que cette armée
défend l'allemagne où le socialisme
rundfunk jamais à g et populaire défend
notre plan de reconstruction du
socialisme que l'amour de l'uniforme est
compatible avec le socialisme
johnny chan notre uniforme n'est pas un
facteur décisif
or l'écart à guérir d'une arme et
surtout un caractère anna may
[Musique]
non ces images n'en pas vains car nous
venons de les filmer et kidira au juste
pourquoi cette foule applaudit mais
regardez écoutez ces jeunes élèves de
l'université de rostock est ce que vous
aimez l'uniforme
[Musique]
vous avez compris la question oui
vous répondez par oui ou par non
[Musique]
c'est difficile
genève ont rencontré une question je
n'ai pas compris je vais vous poser la
question
coop se dérouleront en france
nous allons ne vous laissez pas
surprendre et dit le contraire il
professeurs
[Musique]
les hommes qui incarnent uniforme faire
la paix scheme aps une femme cinq
minutes de culture physique partout l
usine au chantier tous les jours aussi
méthodiquement semble-t-il l'allemagne
de l'est veut la paix c'est vrai elle
veut vivre et tout son effort tant à la
réalisation de ce plan septennale dont
elle attend beau ne serait-ce que l'
équilibre retrouvé dans la vie
quotidienne
car l'allemagne de l'est commencent
seulement à vivre une vie décente une
vie et dont chaque minute est organisée
dont chaque objectif est rappelé en tout
lieu nous ne sommes pas habitués à cela
mais tout le monde est il d'accord c'est
la question que j'ai posée à deux jeunes
étudiantes de l'université de berlin
[Musique]
en principe je suis d'accord mais
quelques foyers ne faudrait pas tant de
papier c'est mon avis personnel mais en
principe la propagande est bonne et
claire moselle pensez vous que ce soit
nécessaire
certainement c'est nécessaire il faut
dire que autre fois il ya deux trois ans
peut-être
il ya presque une maladie ce qu'on
appelait la transe transparente et sp3
willaya le temps qu'on mettait trop
souvent et trop de transparent et ça ça
choque un petit peu les gens et
maintenant on a restreint beaucoup cela
et je trouve que rappeler parfois les
gens
quelques mots d'ordre et quelques idées
quelques buts c'est pas mal mais
voyez-vous pour moi je ne sais pas
encore ce qui m'a le plus frappé de la
nostalgie d'un passé qu'on piétine ou de
cette volonté constante de parler de
paix
[Musique]